A REAL SAFETY TOXIC MATERIAL.
IN THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEES OF LIKE TO
THANK. ALL OF YOU IN ATTENDANCE
FOR COMING HERE IN THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE
HAVING AS.
SOME OF US ARE FAMILIAR WITH
SOME MORE THAN OTHERS. OVER THE
LAST. SEVERAL YEARS. IT'S BECOME
APPARENT THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES ACCEPTANCE
CONTROL. HAS HAD PROBLEMS SOME
FROM SYSTEMATIC.
AND SOME OF THEM JUST GENERAL
BUT THESE PROBLEMS HAVE RESULTED
IN A DISMISSED THE MISMANAGEMENT
OF DEPARTMENT STATUTORY MANDATES
THE LEGISLATURE LOOK CRITICALLY.
AT THESE PROBLEMS AND ATTEMPTING
TO ADDRESS THEM AND LEGISLATURE
HAS CONDUCTED NUMEROUS OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS ON THE DEPARTMENT
APPROVED BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS
CREATED NEW POSITIONS AND SENT
LEGISLATION TO THE GOVERNOR
AIMED AT CORRECTING THE. COURSE
OF THIS BROKE AGENCY AND NOW
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SENATE BILL
EIGHTY THREE ESTABLISH THE
INDEPENDENT. REVIEW PANEL TO
REVIEW AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
THE TSC WITH THE GOAL OF
RESOLVING THE OUTSTANDING
OPERATIONAL PROBLEMS WITHIN DTS
SEE. UP FOR LONG TERM STABILITY
LONG TERM ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LONG TERM TRANSPARENCY. THIS
PEDAL WAS NOT COMPENSATED FOR
THEIR WORK AND I'D LIKE TO
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE.
FANTASTIC WORK THAT THEY HAVE
ACHIEVED OVER TO A TWO YEAR
PERIOD NONE THE LESS THEY WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE DEPARTMENT.
FIND ANSWERS TO FIXING. THE
DEPARTMENT'S.
AILMENTS.
LET ME APPLAUD THE OUR WITNESS
IN THE WHOLE PANEL OF DTS SEE
FOR THE WONDERFUL WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. YOU'VE CONDUCTED TWENTY
FOUR A PUBLIC. MEETINGS YOU'VE
PUBLISHED ELEVEN REPORTS AND
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HAVE COME TO.
THAT HAVE COME TO US TODAY WE
WILL HEAR FROM.
HATCHER. KRAKOW.
ON THE PANEL'S FINAL REPORT AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE WE HAVE THE CHAIR OF THE.
AND VIRAL SAFETY TALKS MATERIAL.
SEVEN MEMBER QUICKER AS FEW
WORDS.
YES OUR FIRST OF ALL I DO WANNA
THANK.
MR GIDEON KRAKOW FOR HIS
EXCELLENT WORK AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I WANT TO THANK.
RACHEL AND JOSH THE.
THE STAFF FOR.
JUST TAKING CARE OF US CHAIRS
AND.
.
SENDING THIS IN MANY OTHER
HEARINGS AND.
PROCEDURES SHOP THEY DO A
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL JOB.
.
SO.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY ISSUE
THAT'S ANY MORE IMPORTANT AND
THE STATE THAN ENSURING
HAZARDOUS WASTE IS MANAGED
PROPERLY. ANDTHAT THE CLEAN UP
SITES ARE CLEANED UP IN THE SAFE
AND RESPONSIBLE WAY.
LATER ON WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SUPERVISE HERE RIGHT HELD
ASSEMBLIES HERE. WHO'S
EXPERIENCED.
MUCH OF THIS WITH HER
CONSTITUENTS.
ALL MENTIONED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
GARCIA'S SANTIAGO. AND OTHERS
AND MYSELF LAST YEAR WHO BROUGHT
UP BILLS BASED UPON WHAT YOUR
COMMITTEE IS DONE.
I'LL NOTE THE NUMBER OF THOSE
BILLS WERE VETOED BECAUSE THE
DICK GOVERNOR FELT THERE WAS
ENOUGH FUNDING TO DO THEM.
THAT'S CERTAINLY AN ISSUE WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT TODAY.
SO THERE'S CERTAINLY BEEN A LOT
OF OF CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
ONE CONCERN I SHARE WITH ALL OF
THE STAKE HOLDERS.
.
IS WITH VERY DIFFERENT VIEW
POINTS RELATED DEPARTMENT'S
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
I UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO IMPROVE THE
DEPARTMENT I GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT EFFORT. AND PERHAPS YOU CAN
TELL US THE DEGREE THAT YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO.
WORK COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD
FROM THE MEETING TWO
TESTIMONIES.
BARBER LEAVE THEIR NEW DIRECTOR
AND THEIR NEW AND THEIR STAFF IS
COMMITTED TO IMPROVE.
I AM ALSO SENSITIVE TO THE MANY
STAKE HOLDERS WHO FEEL THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORT TO IMPROVE
NOT YET YIELDED THE POSITIVE
BENEFITS. STAKEHOLDER YOU'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM. IN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY.
FROM ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
EXPRESS WHAT IMPROVEMENTS
THEY'VE WITNESSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN WEATHER FOR.
WHATEVER.
FUTURE CHANGES THEY WOULD
SUGGEST.
SIR THANK YOU AGAIN MR CRACKER
FOR WORKING SO HARD WITH YOUR
FELLOW PANELISTS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE. AND.
.%
I TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR REPORT
THERE'S STILL A LOT THAT SON
DONE.
IF YOU COULD CONCENTRATE ON
WHAT YOU THINK WE PARTICULARLY
SHOULD JOB. MOVE ON IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE YEAR THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT IN WITH THE ONE
CORRECTION THAT YOU ARE THE
FORMER CHAIR IN NEED OF HELP
EVERYBODY COUNTS. THIS WAS ONLY
IF THEY HAD A TWO YEAR TERM BUT
NONE THE LESS.
PLEASE BEGIN WITH THE OVERVIEW
THANK YOU HM A CASKEY CHAIR CORK
AS SENATOR HILL STAFF. I THINK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS GIDEONKRAKOFF I'M AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ATTORNEY FROM LOS
ANGELES. AND WITH THE SENATE
RULES APPOINTEE IN THE CHAIR OF
THE DTS SEEING APPEND REVIEW
PANEL. OF THIS IS THE THIRD TIME
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE LEGISLATURE ON OUR
WORK.
.
WITH THE IN IN FRONT OF BOTH OF
YOUR COMMITTEES I THINK ABOUT
THIS TIME LAST YEAR. UPSTAIRS
TALKING ABOUT OUR EFFORTS.
ONE ALSO THAT MY OTHER PANEL
MEMBERS OF VICE CHAIR MIKE BUSY
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TO TRAVEL
COULDN'T TRAVEL TODAY. FROM SAN
DIEGO AN ERISA CAMPBELL FROM
ORANGE COUNTY.
SO YOU'RE STUCK WITH ME.
I'LL DO MY BEST BEAR WITH ME I
HAVE THIS. TERRIBLE CHEST COLD.
SO EITHER IT'S GONNA GET WORSE
AS WE GO TODAY OR MAYBE IT'S
GOING TO GET A LITTLE BIT BETTER
AND LOOSEN UP.
SO HAPPY VALENTINE'S DAY I WAS
TRYING TO THINK OF. SOME WAY TO.
MIX VALENTINE'S DAY INDY TSC
BUT I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
YET BUT MAYBE. MAYBE IT'S JUST
SITTING THERE YOU CAN THINK OF
SOME WITTY. WAY TO CONNECT THEM.
SO.
.
SENT ON OUR FINAL REPORT.
YOU HAVE IT IN FRONT OF YOU.
.
FOR WE SUNSET ON JANUARY FIRST
OF THIS YEAR.
THE REPORT MAKES OBSERVATIONS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT. AND ORGANIZES THEM
INTO WHAT WE THINK SHOULD BE
FIVE MAIN PRIORITIES.
CONTINUITY IN EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP.
HUMAN RESOURCES.
FISCAL RESOURCES AND STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS.
TRANSPARENCY.
AND FINALLY REVIEWING THE
GOVERNING STATUTES TO CLEAN THEM
UP.
THEREPORT ALSO. LISTS ALL OUR
PREVIOUS RECOMMENDATIONS AND
METRICS. ALONG WITH THEIR STATUS
IN THE APPENDICES.
LET ME TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THESE
FIVE TOPICS. FIRST JUST THE
BACKGROUND.
AS YOU KNOW WE WERE CREATED IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
WITH THREE MEMBERS. TO REVIEW
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING PERMITTING.
ENFORCEMENT. PUBLIC OUTRAGE
FISCAL MANAGEMENT.
WE WERE TO REPORT TO YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR EVERY NINETY DAYS.
WE STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IN NOVEMBER AND WE HAD
TWENTY EIGHT PUBLIC MEETINGS TO
DISCUSS.
YES HE'S WORK FROM STAKE HOLDERS
ETCETERA.
WE SUBMITTED OVER A HUNDRED
REQUESTS FOR WRITTEN REPORTS.
GOT MANY PRESENTATIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. TWENTY FIVE. TOTAL
TO ONE THE EXCITED NOW WOULD YOU
SITE. WE WANT TO THANK THE
DIRECTOR AND HER STAFF FOR ALL
THE TIME THEY SPENT WITH US.
AS WELL AS OUR TWO GREAT
INTERNAL STAFFERS. OFFICE AND
MIKE SAYING.
AND IN THE END AS YOU INDICATED.
WE SUBMITTED ELEVEN REPORTS TO
YOU.
SO THE FIVE MAIN TOPICS TO
IMPROVE. THE PROGRAMS AND THEN A
SHORT CONCLUSION.
THE FIRST IS THE CONTINUITY IN
LEADERSHIP.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT TURNOVER AT FIVE
DIRECTORS SINCE TWENTY TEN.
IN A PREVIOUS REPORT WE NOTED
THAT THE FIFTEEN EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS EIGHT WERE
HIRED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. IT'S
STILL NEW EXECUTIVE TEAM.
THE PTSD STAFF AGREE THAT THE
TURNOVER AT THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL
HAS A PROBLEM IN A PROBLEM.
THAT'S BEEN DETRIMENTAL TO
EMPLOYEE MORALE.
HOWEVER THERE'S GOOD NEWS THERE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MANY YEARS
THERE IS A STABILIZED LEADERSHIP
TEAM. THANKS TO DIRECTOR LEE.
WHO'S BEEN THERE FOR OVER THREE
YEARS. OF THE FIFTEEN KARTLI TO
SHIP POSITIONS. ONLY ONE IS
STAFFED BY A NEW HIRE ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE TWO COVERED VACANCIES.
THE NEXT LEVEL LEADERSHIP. THE
SENIOR MANAGEMENT TWENTY NINE OF
THIRTY ONE POSITIONS ARE
STAFFED.
SO THERE'S A BETTER STORY TO
TELL THEIR.
THERE HAS TO BE CONTINUITY AT
THE TOP. BUT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO. ESPECIALLY
AS ADMINISTRATIONS CHANGE ALSO
THERE'S AN AGING WORKFORCE TO
DGSE. FIFTY FOUR PERCENT OF THE
EMPLOYEES ARE FIFTY ONE YEARS
OLD.
TO BE A WAVE OF RETIREMENTS
AHEAD. THAT'S OPPORTUNITY BUT
IT'S ALSO A CHALLENGE LOSING
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE.
LEADERSHIP MATTERS. AND YOU ALL
KNOW THIS.
POINT TO.
HUMAN RESOURCES.
THE IRB STRONGLY FEELS THAT
EVALUATING AND INSTITUTING
CHANGES THE DTS THESE INTERNAL
CULTURE IS CRITICAL.
THE DEPARTMENT UNDERSTANDS THIS.
BEGINNING AT TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
EMBARKED ON AN ORGANIZATIONAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENT. TO IDENTIFY
STRENGTHS AND NEEDS A DOCUMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE.
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN DTS
HE REPORTED TO US ON THIS.
AND THEY HAVE. THROUGH THERE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FRANCESCA NEDRY.
MULTI YEAR ROADMAP. FOR TRAINING
AND DEVELOPMENT. ANNUAL
PERFORMANCE REVIEWS. INDIVIDUAL
DEVELOPMENT PLANS HAVE NOT BEEN
HAPPENING.
THE NEW HIRING IN RECRUITMENT
PLAN.
BETTER EMPLOYEE RECOGNITION.
PEER MENTORING AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR PROJECT PLANNING.
AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
PERFORMANCE METRICS TO MONITOR
HOW THEY'RE DOING WITH ALL OF
THIS.
WE AGREE THERE SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT AGAIN THE FUTURE BUDGETS AND
FUTURE LEADERSHIP HAVE TO MAKE
THAT A PRIORITY.
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY IMPROVING THE
CULTURE AN HR ADJUST DEPARTMENT.
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY.
NEXT.
THREE STABLE FISCAL RESOURCES.
IT STARTS ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF
OUR REPORT.
FUNDING IN INFLATION ADJUSTED
DOLLARS HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITH
INCREASED RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
SOME CHARTS SHOWING THIS AS WELL
AS THE STRUCTURAL DEFICITS
STARTING ON PAGE THIRTEEN.
DTS HE'S FIGHTING HAS DECREASED.
IF THE SPECIAL RECENT BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS FOR ARGONAUT AND
EXCITED ARE NOT INCLUDED. BY
SEVENTEEN PERCENT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE.
MOREOVER THE DEPARTMENT'S TWO
LARGEST FUNDING SOURCES FACE
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS.
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT TOSCA.
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT THE H. WCA.
THIS PROBLEM S EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE. BASED ON PROJECTED
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES.
OF PARTICULAR CONCERN IS A SITE
MEDIATION ACCOUNT. FUNDED BY
TOSCA.
COULD USE FOR DIRECTOR MEDIATION
COSTS ON FEDERAL SUPERFUND
ORPHAN SITES THERE ARE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
I THINK THIS YEAR THE COST OR
COMMITMENTS ARE EXPECTED TO
EXCEED OUR APPROPRIATIONS. THAT
MAY LEAVE NO MONEY FOR ORPHANS
SITE CLEANUPS.
THE LESSON PRESSURE ON THE
ACCOUNTS. AND TO ADDRESS THE
TRUE COST OF PROCESSING PERMIT
APPLICATIONS. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
THE BUDGET ACT ELIMINATED THE
FLAT FEE FOR APPLICANTS IN
PERMITTING.
HOWEVER.
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY IS
EXPRESSED UNHAPPINESS WITH THE
SERVICE FEE REQUIREMENT.
THAT IT'S TOO OPEN ENDED.
ONE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE US
MILITARY. ASSERTED. TO US.
APPLICATION COSTS HAVE NOW
INCREASED. TENFOLD.
ON THE OTHER HAND FUNDING IS
NECESSARY FOR MANY CRITICAL
PROGRAMS.
THE PERMIT BACKLOG. OF EXPIRED
PERMITS EXPECTED TO LAST UNTIL
AT LEAST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
SENATORS.
REVIEWING EACH PERMITS
FACILITIES FINANCIAL ASSURANCES
EVERY FIVE YEARS.
MANDATED INSPECTION FREQUENCIES
THAT DON'T EXIST RIGHT NOW.
STAFFING AND GROWTH IN THE NEW
OFFICE OF PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
TRIBAL AFFAIRS YOU.
CONSUMER PRODUCTS GREEN
CHEMISTRY UNIT. SO IT CAN
MEET ITS FULL POTENTIAL.
THE ADMINISTRATION NOTED AS A AS
YOU INDICATED CHAIR WERE
CASTING.
A CHAIR CORK THE LINK BETWEEN
FUNDING AND PERFORMANCE. ITS
VETO MESSAGE FROM LAST YEAR.
REGARDING SEVERAL OF. BUT THE RP
BELIEVES PARTIES NEEDED.
REFORMS.
THE GOVERNOR INDICATED THAT
ADDING NEW RESPONSIBILITIES TO
DEPARTMENT MUST BE UNDERTAKEN
HOLISTICALLY WELL CONSIDERING
RESOURCES. AND FUNDING THAT IS
AVAILABLE. SO THE BUDGET AND THE
FUNDING IS IMPORTANT.
BUT A RELATED ISSUE THEREFORE IS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
PRIORITY FOR.
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
SHOULD BE IMPORTANT PRIORITIES
FOR ALL OF US.
THEY'RE NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE. OF THE CONTINUATION OF
DTS THESE RECENT IMPROVEMENTS AT
ASSURANCES TO YOU.
BUT THE RESOURCE ALLOCATIONS
SUPPORT GOOD INVESTMENTS.
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ARE NEEDED TO MONITOR DTS IS
ONGOING INITIATIVES THAT I'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
AND FRANKLY IT'S DECISION MAKING
ON PROJECTS LIKE EXILE.
THE TSC. HAS A HISTORY OF
MISSING DEADLINES. OFTEN SELF
IMPOSED DEADLINES THAT ARE NOT
REALISTIC. THERE'S A LONG LIST
OF THESE ON PAGE TWENTY EIGHT OF
OUR REPORT. FOR EXAMPLE. DESPITE
THE I. R. P. BREATHING DOWN
THEIR NECKS.
PTSD IS MISSED THE DEADLINE
UNDER SB SIX SEVENTY THREE TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS ESTABLISHING
OR UPDATING CRITERIA. FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE PERMITS IT WAS
DUE BY JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR.
HASN'T BEEN DONE.
THEY ARE BIG KNOWLEDGE IS.
THAT INSUFFICIENT RESOURCES PLAY
A ROLE IN MISSTEP ONCE.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE DTS HE CAN DO
MORE. TO SET REALISTIC DEADLINES
AND CONSIDER HOW TO ACHIEVE A
BALANCE BETWEEN TIMELINESS. AND
GOOD WORK PRODUCT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE BOTH.
OF COURSE IF THE GOVERNOR AND
YOU SEE THE DTS IS DOING HIGH
QUALITY WORK ON TIME. YOU'LL BE
MORE LIKELY TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT WHEN RESOURCES ARE NEEDED.
SO.
DESPITE RECENT IMPROVEMENTS.
WHICH WE DO IT KNOWLEDGE FOR
SURE.
COMMUNITY BUSINESS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STAKE HOLDERS STILL
BELIEVE THERE IS MUCH WORK TO
NEEDS TO BE DONE. IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE COMMUNITY IS EXPRESSED
DISSATISFACTION WITH PROPOSED
CIVIL RIGHTS AND LANGUAGE ACCESS
POLICIES.
BUSINESS STAKEHOLDERS CRITICIZED
PERMIT APPLICATION SERVICE FEES
AND CHARGES FRIEND DIRECT COSTS.
WHAT COUNTY? AND SUPERVISOR SO
WE SIT HERE TODAY. HAS
CRITICIZED ELEMENTS OF THE EXXON
CLEANUP.
FIRST SANTA SUSANNA CONSIDER
STORMS DISTRICT. AND AGAIN THIS
IS FROM A FARM THIS PERSON'S
OPINION. IT'S UNCLEAR TO ME.
WHETHER THE RELEASE OF THE
RECENT DRAFTEE I ARE IS REALLY
GOING TO PROVE. A SIGNIFICANT
STEP FORWARD.
NOW. THE I RP WAS AN ENTITY THAT
STAKE HOLDERS COULD APPROACH TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS ASK QUESTIONS
AND LEARN. BUT WE ARE GONE NOW.
SO THE PANEL MEMBERS TO WONDER
WHERE STAKEHOLDERS WILL GO. IN
THE ABSENCE OF THE IRP. AND WHO
ON A REGULAR BASIS. IS GOING TO
MONITOR THE PROGRESS OF ALL
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
METRICS.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE
AGREES ISSUED A REPORT IN APRIL
OF LAST YEAR.
THAT CONTINUED OVERSIGHT IS
NEEDED.
THE R. P. HAS MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS ALONG THESE
LINES.
INCLUDING. THE GREAT AN
OVERSIGHT BOARD OR OTHER
STRUCTURAL CHANGE TOIMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
TRANSPARENCY.
FINALLY PARTY FIVE. THE
GOVERNING STATUTES THAT MAY NEED
REVISION OR REPEAL AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE.
SHOULD BE REVIEWED TO IMPROVE
ORGANIZATION LEMONADE OBSOLETE
PROVISIONS AND STRENGTHEN SOME
PROVISIONS THAT ARE NOT WORKING
PROPERLY. I CAN JUST TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON ONE AND THEN I'LL
CONCLUDE.
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTIONS
TWO FIVE ONE THREE FIVE. THROUGH
POINT NINE.
ARE EXAMPLES OF A STATUTE THAT
ARE NOT WORKING PROPERLY.
YEARS AGO. THESE ESTABLISHED A
REQUIREMENT TO PRODUCE A STATE
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN.
BUT NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
IT WAS TO BE REVIEWED ANNUALLY
AND REVISED ONCE EVERY THREE
YEARS.
IT WAS TO BE PREPARED
CONJUNCTION WITH PLANTS ADOPTED
BY COUNTIES AND REGIONAL
COUNCILS.
BUT. SOMETIMES THE PLANS WERE
AND SUBMITTED OR THEY COULD NOT
BE APPROVED.
SO AS A RESULT THE STATE WIDE
HAZARDOUS WASTE PLANNING
PRACTICE IS NOT WHAT IT SHOULD
BE.
THE SECTION SHOULD BE REPLACED
BY A NEW PLANNING PROCESS.
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. AND IT REALLY
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO LEAVE YOU ON
THIS.
THE STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
MANAGE TREAT DISPOSE OF ITS
WASTE WITHOUT SHIPPING IT TO
OTHER STATES OR COUNTRIES.
THIS IS OUR OBLIGATION AS A
STATE TO TAKE CARE OF OUR WASTE.
SIR ISSUE OF FAIRNESS AND OF OUR
MIDDLE JUSTICE.
BUT THE RESPONSIBLE WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS IS TO THINK
STATE WHAT TO THINK FAIRLY.
DECIDE THESE FACILITIES IN A WAY
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
OUR STATE DO NOT ALWAYS BEAR. A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN.
IT REQUIRES PLANNING PROBABLY
SOME NEW STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
AND FUNDING.
BUT ANY OF IT.
THE GOVERNING STATUTES WILL
CREATE REALISTIC EXPECTATIONS.
AND HELP THE TSC FOCUS ON ITS
MISSION.
SO IN BRIEF CONCLUSION DGSE HAS
MADE CONSIDERABLE PROGRESS OVER
THESE LAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
THE GOVERNOR.
INDEED HE IS THE DIRECTOR WE
STABILIZE THE LEADERSHIP TEAM.
PTSD IS WORKING. TO EVALUATE ITS
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE. AND YOUR
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS HAVE MADE A
REAL DIFFERENCE FOR COST
RECOVERY. PERMITTING.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
CERTAINLY FOR EXIDE.
AND THE PROBLEM IS WORKING ON
MANY OF THE MATRIX IN OUR
REPORT.
BUT THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE.
THE DEPARTMENT IS ONLY BEGINNING
TO CONSIDER AND IMPLEMENT ITS
ORGANIZATIONAL PLANS.
YOU HAVE THESE TWO SERIOUS
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS.
IT'S NOT YET CERTAIN WHETHER DTS
SEES PUBLIC PARTICIPATION THAT
AJ WORK WILL REALLY LEAD TO IN
DURING IMPROVEMENTS.
THERE'S STILL A REAL CHALLENGE.
BETWEEN BALANCING WORK PRODUCT.
QUALITY.
AND TIMELINESS.
SO IN LIGHT OF ALL THIS.
LEAVE THERE'S A CONTINUED NEED.
TO ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY.
REGULARLY MONITOR HOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING WITH
METRICS.
AS WELL AS TO INQUIRE INTO ITS
ONGOING. FINISHES AND DECISION
MAKING.
PART OF THAT OF COURSE. IS YOUR
ROLE.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY. THIS OPPORTUNITY
CHAIRS. AND I'M CERTAINLY
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER A FEW
QUESTIONS OF MY VOICE CAN HOLD
UP.
THANK YOU.
LET'S START OFF AT THE END WHERE
YOU CONCLUDED.
WITH A NEW FRAMEWORK.
AND YOU KNOW SOME SOURCE
REDUCTION CAN YOU FLESH THAT OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE WHAT THAT.
LOOKS LIKE I MEAN I I SEE THE
ONE SIDE IS A TEDIOUS CODE WORK
TO LOOK FOR REDUNDANCIES AND GO
OVER. THIRTY YEARS OF.
OF FINE LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
PRIDE BUT WHAT TO HOW HUGE IS
THAT. NEW FRAMEWORK.
ORIENTATION.
SUGGESTING.
IT. SO IT.
I GUESS THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS
THERE.
.
THE.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS ABOUT THE.
YOU KNOW THE THE HEALTH.
SAFETY CODE.
EXCERPTS.
WHICH YOU CAN. YOU CAN FIND YOU
KNOW RIGHT HERE.
.
TO HAVE HAPPENED THROUGH THE
YEARS AT IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
DEPARTMENT REGULATIONS ACTUALLY
ARE QUITE SMALL IN COMPARISON TO
THE CODE.
WHAT SEEMS TO HAPPEN THROUGH THE
YEARS IS THAT THERE'S BEEN?
THROUGH ACCRETION.
EACH YEAR. A NEW ISSUE A NEW
CHALLENGE HAS BEEN DETERMINED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT IT'S BEEN PUT
IN THE LEGISLATION.
BUT AS A RESULT MAYBE TO DEAL
WITH THE NEEDS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OR. OTHER.
MERGING ISSUES. YOU GET A CODE
THAT IS THIS. LARGE.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS CROSS
REFERENCE THEY'RE OBSOLETE
THINGS LIKE THE HAZARDOUS WASTE.
ABOUT PLANNING STATUTES THAT ARE
REFERENCED. AND. IT BECOMES
REALLY DIFFICULT EITHER FROM YOU
KNOW LAWYERS TO TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND. SO IT'S A VERY VERY
LARGE JOB TO DO THAT MAYBE IT IS
SOMETHING. THAT FRANKLY IN THE
END PROVED TO BE. INFEASIBLE BUT
WE MADE THE RECOMMENDATION THAT
THE. LAW REVISION COMMISSION OR
SOMEBODY VERY SMART.
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY BE LOCKED
IN A ROOM FOR A FEW MONTHS IN
AND TRIED TO YOU KNOW SHRINK
THIS DOWN. SO THAT CROSS
REFERENCES AND IT'S.
BETTER.
.
EASIER TO MANAGE.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS ABOUT THE
STRUCTURE. I THINK IT'S RELATED
ISSUE.
THERE HAVE BEEN. ISSUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT FOR ALL THE REASONS
WE DISCUSSED IN THE FIVE
PRIORITIES IN OUR REPORT.
AND AGAIN I THINK. PERHAPS
INSTEAD OFFIGURING OUT IN THIS
GOES BACK TO THE HISTORY OF THE
DEPARTMENT WHICH CAME OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH MANY
YEARS AGO. THAT MAYBE MAYBE THE
STRUCTURE.
.
YEAH.
AS. THE NEED.
FOR EXAMINERS. MAYBE WHAT USED
TO BE MORE OF A PERMITTING
AGENCY IS NOT REALLY MORE OF A
SITE CLEANUP AGENCY. WITH
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER CONCERNED
ABOUT ALL THE SITES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE IN MAYBE THE STRUCTURE
THAT WORKED WHAT WAS SPLIT OFF
IN THE NINETIES FROM D. PH. OR
THE EIGHTIES ISN'T WHAT IT
SHOULD BE TODAY.
MAYBE INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
THOSE STRUCTURAL ISSUES.
WHAT WHAT A SWITCHER IS DONE
INSTEAD IS ADD A DISPATCHER THAT
STATUTE?
AND MAYBE NOW TWENTY YEARS
LATER.
IT'S NOT REALLY WHERE YOU WANT
TO BE. WHERE MAYBE YOU'VE GOT A
STRUCTURE THAT PERHAPS DOESN'T
FIT? WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING? THE OTHER HAND YOU HAVE
THIS CODE. THAT IS VERY
UNWIELDY.
I DON'T HAVE A SILVER BULLET FOR
YOU WANT BUT THE BEST STRUCTURE
SHOULD BE.
UP. THERE IS A CONCERN THAT ALL
THE WORK WE'VE HAD ALL THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
YOU WANNA WORST CASE IS JUST
GONNA BE ANOTHER REPORT IT'S PUT
ON THE SHELF THAT NOBODY READS
AND THERE'S BEEN SO MANY REPORTS
ON THIS DEPARTMENT. AND WE DON'T
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND THERE WAS NOT CONSENSUS
AMONG THE PANEL WHAT WOULD BE
THE BEST STRUCTURE. BUT THERE
ARE THINGS THAT. IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO HANDLE IN A.
TRANSPARENT WAITED DOESN'T EXIST
NOW.
IT'S IT'S A FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT. CORE MISSION TO
PERMIT SITES THAT ARE HANDLING
YOUR WAIST AND THEN DEALING
WITH.
THE REPERCUSSIONS OF ALL THAT
HANDLING OF WASTED MAYBE THE
MISHANDLING OF THE WAYS THAT'S
CREATED. CONTAMINATION AND
HAZARDS ON THOSE SITES AGAIN I
THINK IT GETS BACK TO THE YEAR
THE LARGER QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE IS THAT YOU KNOW. EVERYBODY
IN MODERN CALIFORNIA.
EXPECT CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES
EXPECTS CERTAIN A CERTAIN
STANDARD OF LIVING DECREASE JUST
WASTES NO WE CAN WORK ON THAT
THAT ONE SIDE TO REDUCE THE
SOURCE OF CREATING WAYS BUT WHAT
WE DO THAT I MEAN I. HAVE SAID
PUBLICLY. AND AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THAT WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
RECYCLE OUR BATTERIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE ANSWER
IS NOT JUST TO SHIP THEM OUT.
OUT NOW. IS CERTAINLY VERNON
DOESN'T WANT A SITE BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THEY'VE HAD THE SITE AT
EXCITE BUT WE STILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THESE TECHNOLOGIES IN
MODERN SOCIETY AND AND AS I MAKE
A LAW THAT SAYS THIS IS NOW
COULD BE HAZARDOUS WASTE PRODUCT
IN. CALIFORNIA I DON'T ALWAYS
THINK ABOUT WHERE IS IT GOING TO
GO AND WHAT'S THE TREATMENT OF
THAT SO UNIT. IS THAT WHAT WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT IS THIS
WHOLE RESTRUCTURING OF THAT THE
HELL WE HANDLE WASTE INSTEAD OF
JUST SAYING GET IT OUT OF MY YOU
KNOW. OFF AT THIS LOCATION AND
PUT IT SOMEWHERE.
IF THAT SEEMS TO BE THE THE
RESPONSIBLE A WAY TO ADDRESS IT
AND.
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN SO CAUGHT
UP IN. THE DAY TO DAY WHETHER
IT'S EXIDE SAID TO SUSANNAH.
HUNTERS POINT. AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS THESE.
VERY EXISTENCE FROM STANCES THAT
I I THINK IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TO
STEP BACK AND DO SOME OF THIS
PLANNING ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE POOR TALKS ABOUT IS THAT THE
SOURCE REDUCTION EFFORTS. HAVE
FALLEN BY THE WAYSIDE A LITTLE
BIT AS OTHER PRIORITIES HAVE
BEEN PUT IN THIS CODE SO I THINK
STEPPING BACK AND GIVING THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THE LEGISLATURE.
IN THE ABILITY TO BREATHE A
LITTLE BIT AND FIGURE OUT. WHERE
ARE WE GOING WITH THIS IS THIS
THE BEST? WAY TO HANDLE IT I
THINK IS THE RESPONSIBLE THING.
BUT GOING BACK AGAIN TO YOUR
QUESTION ON WHAT A
STRUCTURE-COULD LOOK LIKE SOME
THINGS THAT
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER IS.
NO REGULATIONS.
IT'S VERY COMMON FOR GOVERNING
BOARDS TO HAVE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY IN PUBLIC TO CONSIDER.
YOU HAD A GOVERNING BOARD WITH
AUTHORITY. WHICH WE CERTAINLY
DIDN'T HAVE. THESE REGULATIONS
ON SIX SEVENTY THREE WOULD BE
DONE BY NOW. EARN THE METRICS
AND ALL THE INTERNAL THINGS THAT
THE R. P. PUT TOGETHER THAT
COULD BE SOMETHING THAT IS
LOOKED AT. CERTAINLY EXIDE WHICH
IS GOING TO GO ON FOR MANY MANY
YEARS TO DO THAT IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY. WITH
APPOINTEES.
BUT THE STORY. EXPERIENCED WITH
FIXED TERMS SO THAT THEY HAVE
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY THAT ALSO
CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THIS.
LEADERSHIP TURNOVER MIGHT BE
VALUABLE BUT OF COURSE. TO DO
THIS IN A PUBLIC WAY WITH THE
PUBLIC WHETHER IT'S FOR A
PARTICULAR SITE OR OTHER THINGS
CAN COME. GET ANSWERS HAVE A
BOARD THAT CARES WITH SOME
AUTHORITY TRY TO TO GET
QUESTIONS AND BREAK THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT OF THE INSULARITY.
THAT SOME STILL OBSERVE WITH
THIS DEPARTMENT. THESE ARE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT. YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT A NEW STRUCTURE I
THINK YOU SHOULD CONSIDER THAT
AGAIN THAT'S JUST REALLY
SPEAKING FOR ME. THERE WAS NOT A
CONSENSUS AMONG THE PANEL ON HOW
TO DO THIS WE LEFT IT TO YOUR
BRIGHTER MINDS.
BUT. I'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO. TWO
THOUSAND TEN WHEN I GOT ELECTED
AND I HAD A GERMAN CORKS JOB ET.
VIRAL SAFETY IN TOXIC MATERIAL
SO I'VE HAD PLENTY OF. HEARINGS
ON HIGH. DTS SEE. AND THERE'S
ALWAYS EEN THIS CHALLENGE I
GUESS OF THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
THE CHICKEN AND THE EGG DO WE
GIVE THE DEPARTMENT MORE MONEY
WITH MORE POSITIONS TO FIX IT OR
THEY GET A FUNDAMENTALLY FIX.
THE WAY THAT THEY OPERATE I
THINK SOME OF THE TRANSPARENCY
PRIORITIES.
ATTACHED AT THE QUESTION IS IS
ON THE.
THE SACRED MEDIATION ACCOUNT AND
THAT TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL
ACCOUNT THIS SEEMS YOU'VE
HIGHLIGHTED THOSE ACCOUNTS IS
BEING SHORT OF MONEY. IT AND
WE'VE ALWAYS YOU YOUR TESTIMONY
AND THE REPORT INDICATES THAT
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY FEELS
LIKE. THEY.
TEN TIMES AS MUCH FOR THAT THE
SERVICES IS ENOUGH IS THAT A
GENERAL FUND.
PRIORITY THAT THAT THAT THAT
THE.
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT TWO TO
AUGMENT NOW IT'S SO THAT WE
DON'T.
WE DON'T START CHASING ALL THE.
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE OCCURRED OR
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT ARE
OCCURRING ARE ORPHANED SITES IN
THE SUPERFUND SITES.
YEAH I.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT
QUESTION.
OF. THE ACCOUNTS DO HAVE
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS.
.
WHY EXACTLY THAT IS?
WHERE ARE?
APPROPRIATE FEES. MIGHT BE.
HOW WE ARE PLANNING FOR THE
FUND SITES GET TURNED OVER TO
THE STATE WHICH THEN INCREASES
THE OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE?
COSTS FOR THE STATE I THINK IT
BE WORTH WHILE AND.
JUST BE HONEST WITH YOU HAVING
CRUNCH THE NUMBERS TO REALLY
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. WITH
CERTAINTY BUT IT BE WORTH WHILE
I THINK FOR YOUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES AND OTHERS TO
REALLY LOOK AT THIS.
AND DETERMINE. YOU KNOW WHAT
ENDED DEPARTMENTS WRITTEN SOME
REPORTS ON THIS ON THIS SR
EIGHT.
SHORTFALL.
REALLY FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE AND.
AND. WHERE THE DEPARTMENT IS IN
TERMS OF ITS FUNDING BUT AGAIN?
I THINK A PART OF THAT HAS TO
DEAL WITH ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU FEEL THAT THE DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT WISELY. AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS MEETING ITS
EXPECTATIONS ONE OF THE THINGS
I'LL MENTION. IS. EITHER HAD
BEEN A LOT OF.
BUDGET.
OF CHANGE CHANGES.
AND FINANCE LETTERS ETCETERA
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT DIFFERENT THINGS OVER
THE PAST. THREE TO FIVE YEARS
AND WE ASKED THE DEPARTMENT AND
WHAT THEY DO IS. WHEN THEY.
MAKE THOSE REQUESTS OF YOU THEY
PUT TOGETHER WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO. WITH CERTAIN TIME LINES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND WE ASK
THE DEPARTMENT HEY. LET'S LOOK
AT THOSE LAST FIVE YEARS A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS AND.
TELL US HAVE YOU MET ALL THE
THINGS YOU WERE GOING TO DO. AND
FRANKLY WE THAT REPORT WE DIDN'T
GET UNTIL OUR LAST MEETING AND
IT WAS REALLY TOO LATE TO
ANALYZE IT.
MAYBE IT'S YOUR JOB TO LOOK AT
THAT STUFF BUT AGAIN YOU HAVE SO
MANY OTHER PRIORITIES.
SO I I THINK THERE IS SOME AND
THE MINISTRATIONS CERTAINLY IS
LOOKING AT THAT NO DOUBT. BE
HELPFUL.
FOR WHICH IN A TRANSPARENT WAY
TO HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE BUDGET. I MEAN THERE'S THERE
ARE THE STATES OR FAN SITES THAT
THE ORPHAN FOR REASON WE DON'T
HAVE A RESPONSIBLE PERSON AND
NOW WE'RE GETTING THE FEDERALS
WERE FAN SITES THAT ARE COMING
IN AND WE AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
SHORT OF. OF JOE ON THE ON THE
POSITIONS ON PAGE TWENTY
REFERENCE THE FIVE.
POSITIONS THAT WERE REDIRECTED
FROM.
THE.
WHERE WAS THAT CONFERENCE THERE
WERE FIVE SITES THAT WERE READ
TO RID OUR FIVE POSITIONS THAT
WERE REDIRECTED FOR?
AS I GUESS THE REMEDIATION WORK
AND YOUR RECOMMENDATION IS THAT
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT MAKING
THOSE PERMANENT RATHER THAN RE
DIRECT THEM. AND I MADE A NOTE
IN.
I SHOULD ADMIT A DASH HERE.
BECAUSE YOU WENT THROUGH THIS
SITE MITIGATION REPORT AND
THAT'S IN THE SECTION WHERE
WE'VE GOT WE CREATED THESE
LIMITED TERMS SEVERAL YEARS OF
LIMITED TERM.
.
POSITIONS.
AND THEN THERE WERE FIVE
REDIRECTED POSITIONS.
IN MY READING.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT.
IF THAT WAS RECOMMENDATION I
THINK WAS MADE.
.
YEAH EARLY ON.
THE IF YOU RECALL THERE WAS A
BIG ISSUE WITH HUNDREDS OF.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR SOMETHING OF COST
RECOVERY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HADN'T PURSUED. AND THEY BROUGHT
THOSE PEOPLE AND. TO SORT OF
THOUGHT IT THROUGH THAT.
.
I THINK THERE'S TWO OBSERVATIONS
TO MAKE ON THAT ONE IS. THAT IN
THE END MOST OF THOSE COSTS WERE
SIMPLY WRITTEN OFF. THAT MONEY
WAS LOST.
THE OTHER OBSERVATION WHICH IS
MORE POSITIVE IS THAT I THINK
THOSE POSITIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT AS A WHOLE HAVE MUCH
BETTER COST RECOVERY PROCEDURES
IN PLACE. I'M CONFIDENT THE
GOING FORWARD WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SEE THAT KIND OF PROBLEM AGAIN.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING.
AT ANOTHER THING THAT'S RELATED
TO THAT IS THE TECHNOLOGY.
DEPARTMENT MADE THE TRANSITION
TO A CALIPHATES FISCALE BUT
STILL THEY'RE BILLING PRISSY. I
T. TECHNOLOGY IS OUTDATED THAT
MADE A REQUEST TO GET A NEW
SYSTEM IN PLACE BUT THAT WAS
LIKE FIVE STEPS TO TAKE TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO. THE I. T.
HAVE TO BE IMPROVED OF. THESE
POSITIONS I THINK PARTICULARLY
THOSE FIVE WERE TO GET THE COST
RECOVERY HOUSE IN ORDER.
I THINK WE FEEL THAT THE COST
RECOVERY HOUSE IS IN ORDER NOW.
AND I THINK THERE WAS A REASON
WHY. IN A YEAR AND A HALF TWO
YEARS LATER THOSE POSITIONS CAN
BE REPURPOSED.
OKAY A GERMAN COURT QUESTIONS.
TOM PERSONAL LOAN ACCOUNT.
EMPLOYMENT CHAIRMAN WHY CASKEY
IN.
BRINGING UP ALL THOSE QUESTIONS
THAT I HAVE VERY LITTLE LEFT TO
SAY.
.
YES EXCELLENT JOB SENATOR.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND.
DID YOU FEEL DURING THE COURSE
OF TIME PARTICULARLY AFTER.
.
DIRECTOR LEE CAME ON BOARD THAT
YOU WERE GETTING GOOD
COOPERATION IN YOUR.
EXAMINATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
FROM DEPARTMENT MEMBERS.
YES I THINK THE ANSWER IS YES.
OF. THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT. DID ITS BEST TO PROVIDE US
WITH. THE INFORMATION AND THEY
SIGNED A STAFFER TO HELP US.
AND THAT WAS A LOT OF WORK FOR
THEM AND APPLAUD THE DIRECTOR.
UP FOR THAT.
ONE THING TO MENTION IS SORT OF
OUR INDEPENDENT IN A ROLE.
AND.
OF.
PERHAPS IN THE BEGINNING WHAT
SOME THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
WHERE?
?
THE I RP WAS SORT OF PART OF
THE TEAM.
I I THINK. TOWARDS THE END SORT
OF THE INDEPENDENT ROLE OF THE
DEPARTMENT. YOU KNOW SORT OF
YOUR PREVENTED THAT A LITTLE BIT
IF YOU FOLLOW ME NOBODY LIKES
INSPECTOR GENERAL OR AN
INDEPENDENT BODY RUNNING AROUND
IN THE DEPARTMENT. I'D HOPE THAT
THERE WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT.
DIFFERENT OF A RELATIONSHIP IN
THE END IT DIDN'T REALLY TURN
OUT. TO BE THAT WAY IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF AN ARM'S
LENGTH TYPE OF. A RELATIONSHIP.
SO FOR EXAMPLE. IN THE END THE.
THE RP WAS NOT ALLOWED. FOR WAS
STRONGLY. RECOMMENDED AGAINST
GOING AND VISITING THE DISTRICT
OFFICES TO SORT OF INTERVIEW THE
STAFF.
CANDID WAY TO SORT OF GET TO
KNOW THEM.
THE. DEPARTMENT THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE DISRUPTIVE SO WE ENDED UP NOT
DOING THAT.
WE GOT OTHER INFORMATION IN
OTHER WAYS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
FOUND. MORE APPROPRIATE.
SO THEY WORK VERY HARD. YOU CAN
SEE THAT. MOUNT OF INFORMATION
THEY GAVE US.
AND WHAT IT THANK THEM FOR THAT.
BUT I'LL SAY IN FAIRNESS IT WAS
A BIT OF A ARM'S LENGTH
RELATIONSHIP.
SO I'M. THAT'S INTERESTING SO I
WAS A MANAGEMENT CONSULTANT WITH
MCKINSEY AND COMPANY OVER COURSE
OF THE YEAR.
I THINK IT I THINK IT'S A SHAME
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO TALK TO
FOLKS BECAUSE ARM. TALKING TO
PEOPLE CANDIDLY ABOUT THEIR JOBS
YOU'RE GOING TO LEARN A LOT MORE
THAN YOU CAN FROM JUST READING
REPORTS.
SO CERTAINLY I WOULD RECOMMEND
SO. SENATOR. CONNIE LEIVA. WHOSE
DISTRICT THIS IS DAN HAS
RECOMMEND HAS A BILL WHICH WOULD
SET UP. AN INDEPENDENT BOARD.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THIS BILL.
IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER HERE
BUT I TEN POINT I'D APPRECIATE
ANY DOUBLE THAT BILL IS ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR WHETHER WORKING
OUT DETAILS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SHE ATE ANY INSIGHTS YOU HAVE
EITHER NOW OR LATER ON.
TALKING DIRECTLY WITH SARAH OUR
OFFICES. INTO WHAT YOU SEE IS
THE PLUSES AND MINUSES OF THAT
WAY THAT BOARD IS STRUCTURED.
YEAH I'LL DEFINITELY. BE
AVAILABLE TO COMMENT ON THAT TO
HAVE A LOOK AT THE BILL LATELY.
ALL RIGHT WELL CERTAINLY OUR
STAFFS WILL GET A HOLD OF YOU.
AND DAD TRY AND GET YOUR INPUT
ON THAT AND I I DO THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT.
THAT. WE'RE DEAD IF THERE IS A
FOLLOW ON BOARD. THAT'D BE ABLE
TO TALK WITH PEOPLE IN A.
HE'S A RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE
FRANKLY THE PEOPLE AT THE. AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL KNOW MORE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON AND HOW TO
FIX IT THAN ANYONE ELSE DOES AND
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY EXPERIENCE.
AS A MANAGEMENT CONSULTANT DOING
MUCH THE SAME KIND OF WORK YOU
DID THAT THE BEST INFORMATION.
COME FROM THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY
WHO DO THE JOBS DIRECTLY SO I
THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT AND WILL.
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS IN
EXPLICITLY.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T FIGHT.
AND THREATENED TO VETO THE BILL.
I THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL WE PUT IT
IN THERE AND WE'LL DO I'LL DO
ALL WE CAN TO GET IT IN THERE.
GO AHEAD YEAH CERTAINLY AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS.
.
YOU WANT TO PUT SOMETHING IN
PLACE THAT'S GONNA MAKE THE
DEPARTMENT FUNCTION. BETTER.
MORE SMOOTHLY. WE DON'T WANT TO
PUT. NEW STRUCTURES IN PLACE
THEY'RE GONNA SLOW THINGS DOWN
RIGHT AND AND.
GUM UP THE WORKS SO AGAIN IT IS
IT'S THERE'S. THIS BALANCE OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE JOB GETS
DONE WELL AND ON TIME. AND.
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WHAT IF ANYTHING COMES AFTER THE
RP CERTAINLY KEEP THAT IN MIND.
VERY GOOD.
SO THERE CERTAINLY IS AN ISSUE
OF RESOURCES. THERE ALSO IS
PROBABLY AN ISSUE OF
STREAMLINING OF.
THINGS THAT GET IN THE WAY OF
DOING THE JOB.
.
SO THOSE ARE ALSO THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT. AS WE STUDY A
REPORT FURTHER AND AS WE LOOK AT
PERHAPS RE DRAFTING. THE
LEGISLATION.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY COME BACK TO
YOU AND THE DEPARTMENT AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO THAT WOULD
MAKE THE DEPARTMENT'S WORK COME
OFF MORE QUICKLY.
AND HOPEFULLY LESS EXPENSIVELY.
YES SEVEN I THOUGHT I WAS ALL
DONE BUT TO IF YOU. WANT TO COME
HOME NOW WILL WILL WILL TALK TO
YOU AND WE'LL ALSO TALK TO THE
DEPARTMENT. AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT.
IF THERE ARE STRUCTURAL CHANGES
THAT CAN SPEED UP THE WORK SO
THANK YOU.
I DID FORGET ONE QUESTION I WANT
TO ASK YOU AND UNDER THE FIRST
PRIORITY TO LEADERSHIP HE TALKED
ABOUT THE CRIMINAL. OFFICER
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS IN THE
ENFORCEMENT AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAM BECAUSE WE'RE
WAITING FOR A FINAL REPORT FROM
THE.
.
THE ERT ON THEIR INISH INITIAL
pA CONFERENCE OF STUDY THAT OF
WHAT POSITIONS THAT THEY NEED.
AND.
NATURALLY RESOURCES.
.
CAN YOU PUT.
TAKE THAT CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
ON EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
ENFORCEMENT IF THEY DO NEED
RESOURCES. PUT YOUR
TRANSPARENCY.
LANDS ON THAT AND WHAT ARE THE
CONDITIONS ARE YOU WHAT ARE THE.
HOW DO WE IMPROVE THAT? RESPONSE
TEAM WITH REGARD TO THE PUBLIC
AND THE DEBT IS THE
TRANSPARENCY.
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN
ARTICULATED THE OTHER.
HE'S.
WELL I MEAN.
I GET OR SHOULD WE I GUESS IF
YOU PUT YOUR MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANT YOU KNOW HAT BACK ON
AND YOU KNOW YOU FOLKS.
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERTISE IN.
AND TRYING TO AS SORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THE VARIOUS.
.
YOU KNOW.
FOLKS IN STATE GOVERNMENT ARE.
A FIRING ON ALL CYLINDERS THIS
PARTICULAR UNIT HAS. HAD A LOT
OF LEADERSHIP AND STAFFING
PROBLEMS THROUGH THE YEARS WHEN
WE TRY TO DO IS GIVE THEM
CERTAIN METRICS. YOU KNOW.
CONDOMS HOW MANY CASES ARE YOU
FILING IT'LL.
AND IT'S ALL IN THE REPORT YOU
KNOW HOW MANY HOW LONG DOES IT
TAKE YOU TO DO. WHAT KIND OF
PENALTIES ARE YOU OF PUTTING
TOGETHER WHAT YOUR STAFF
TURNOVER?
?
WE TRIED OUR BEST TO SENATORS
IN.
YOU KNOW.
TRY TO GIVE SOME OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA AND HOW TO MEASURE HOW
THESE FOLKS ARE DOING OTHER
THING AND JUST TO BE CANDID WITH
THE DEPARTMENT IS. THIS PAY.
SOME OF THESE JOBS THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR UNIT DON'T PAY AS
MUCH AS SOME OF THE COUNTIES. OR
CITIES DO. SO IT'S HARD FOR THEM
AND JOSH KNOWS THAT MISTER
TOOGOOD KNOWS THIS FROM HIS TIME
THERE IT'S HARD TO ATTRACT GOOD
PEOPLE AND KEEP THEM. BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING PUBLISHED A LOT
OF OTHER AGENCIES. THERE'S ALSO
AN ISSUE THAT IS A LABOR ISSUE
AMONG THE DIFFERENT BARGAINING
UNITS OF THE DEPARTMENT. BETWEEN
THE STAFF SCIENTISTS. AND SOME
OF THE OTHER STAFFERS THAT
THERE'S AN INN IN THE INEQUALITY
THERE. WHICH AGAIN HAS TO DO
WITH BARGAINING UNITS IN OTHER
THINGS.
AND THAT WE JUST JUST THE MORALE
ISSUES BUT. TO ME IT SEEMS THAT
IF.
IF IF FOLKS. WANT TO COME TO YOU
FOR MORE RESOURCES IT YOU GIVE
THEM CRITERIA THAT YOU FEEL
SATISFIED WITH. THAT ENABLE TO
YOU TOO.
ASSESS HOW THEY'RE DOING.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT AS A WHOLE NEEDS MORE
OF THAT. THAT WAS A MAJOR FOCUS
OF OUR WORK PUTTING.
TIVOLI.
OBJECTIVE PERFORMANCE METRICS
IN PLACE THAT WE THOUGHT MEANT
SOMETHING.
AND TRYING TO MONITOR THAT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WE'RE NOT LONGER
THERE TO MONITOR. AND AGAIN AS
YOU ALL KNOW WHAT I KNOW YOUR
SCIENTIST. SENATOR QUIRK YOU
KNOW.
YOU KNOW THE.
THE QUALITY YOUR CONCLUSIONS
ALSO DEPENDS ON. THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA THAT YOU'RE GETTING.
AND THAT'S VERY HARD TO MONITOR
AS WELL SO THERE'S NO SILVER
BULLETS FOR ALL OF THIS BUT WE
DO OUR BEST.
HE'D LIKE.
THERE. YEAH.
SO IMPRESSED BECAUSE I REMEMBER
WHEN YOU FIRST STARTED A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO AND AND JUST THE
THE THE BREADTH AND DEPTH OF
YOUR KNOWLEDGE NOW AND AN
EXPLOITATION. OF IT'S JUST
EXTRAORDINARY AND SO HELPFUL. IN
IS THE FORMER CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHEN ALL OF THIS I
THINK STARTED WE. REALLY SAW A
LOT OF THE CHALLENGES THAT DTS
SHE HAD.
AND IN ONE OF THE THE FIRST
COMMENT THAT YOU MADE WAS THE. A
AND THE RECORD KIND OF OLD.
FIRST OBSERVATION WAS THE THE
TURNOVER AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
THAT BROUGHT OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
DID YOU DETERMINE FROM YOUR
ANALYSIS OF WHAT YOU SAW ANY
PARTICULAR. REASON FOR THAT I
GUESS THE CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT
THAT MAY WE MAY SEE IF IF THOSE.
ISSUES HAVEN'T BEEN DEALT WITH
THEIR HAND OR WE MAY SEE THAT
GOING FORWARD.
YEAH IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
ASK. THEM TO GET TWO
OBSERVATIONS WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHY DID THIS PERSON
LEAVE FOR THAT PERSON LEAVE.
YOU KNOW IT IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY ALWAYS HAS THEIR OWN
REASONS YOU KNOW SOMEBODY TOOK A
BETTER JOB SOMEBODY HAD. HEALTH
ISSUES IN THE FAMILY.
YOU KNOW THERE'S ALWAYS SEEM TO
BE.
BUT A ONE OFF BASIS VERY
JUSTIFIABLE REASONS. BUT THEN
WHEN YOU LOOK AT LOOK AT ALL OF
IT. YOU YOU SEE WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN FOR
EXAMPLE. I THINK OF THE TOP.
FIFTEEN OR THIRTY LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS LIKE THREE OF THEM HAD
BEEN THERE FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS.SO I THINK YOU YOU TURN
AROUND AND SAY WELL INTO
SOMETHING. MORE IMPORTANT DEEPER
GOING ON HERE. I THINK THAT'S
THE SORT OF SECOND POINT WHICH
IS THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT
TO WORK IN A DEPARTMENT.
THAT.
.
IS SUBJECT TO A LOT OF THE
CRITICISM.
WHERE MAYBE THERE IS HIGHER PAY
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR?
SO I THINK.
.
OF ALL OF OUR JOBS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE FOCUS SO MUCH ON THE
HUMAN RESOURCES ASPECT. IS TO
MAKE THE DEPARTMENT DATE OF A
MORE INVITING PLACE TO WORK TO
TRY TO FIND MECHANISMS TO
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT FROM
WITHIN.
TO TRY TO PRAISE THE DEPARTMENT
WHERE IT'S IT'S DOING A GOOD
JOB.
SO I THINK IT'S IT'S A BALANCE
OF THOSE THINGS WE'RE HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT TWO AND A HALF YEARS
LATER. THERE APPEARS AT LEAST AT
THAT LEADERSHIP LEVEL TO BE MORE
CONTINUITY.
DIRECTOR LEE IS A VERY DIFFICULT
JOB.
BUT YOU KNOW SHE STUCK IT OUT IT
HASN'T BEEN EASY FOR HER AND YOU
KNOW I APPLAUD HER FOR THAT. BUT
I'M REALLY HOPEFUL AND BUDGETS
HAVE TO REFLECT THIS. THAT THIS
HR WORK ABOUT INTERNALLY
CHAMPIONING THE STAFF.
AT DOING EVALUATIONS DOING THE
TRAININGS DOING THE SUPPORT.
OVER TIME.
IT'S GOING TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
AT THIS DEPARTMENT THAT'S THE
HOPE CENTER HELP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO END BY JUST THANKING
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE.
YOU'VE DONE. YOU MUST OF HAD
TWO FULL TIME JOBS.
AND.
.
WE KNOW HOW MUCH YOU KNOW YOU'VE
WORKED.
WE ARE GOING TO CALL UPON YOUR
EXPERTISE.
HOPE WE ALLOW YOU THOUGH TO GET
BACK TO YOUR DAY JOB SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO START THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION. OF THE FIRST PERSON UP
FOR COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT. IS
GOING TO BE.
.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SUPERVISOR
HILDA'S LEASE. AND SHE HAS SAYS
SOMEONE COMING OUT NEXT TO
SOMEONE'S COMING UP WITH THEIR.
WILL ASK YOU IF YOU CAN TO KEEP
IT TO ABOUT TEN MINUTES.
APPROXIMATELY.
.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
THE SUPERVISOR WAS SECRETARY OF
LABOR CONGRESSWOMAN STATE
SENATOR STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
.
AND FRANKLY THE THE JOB A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR IN LOS ANGELES IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT JOBS IN
OUR STATE.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HRE TODAY FANS.
I'M PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
ANY SUGGESTIONS YOU WHEN YOUR
EXPERTS HAVE ABOUT.
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO BE ON THE?
RECEIVING SIDE OF THE DEPARTMENT
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
HOW YOU SEE THE STRUCTURES MIGHT
CHANGE. TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
WORK FOR THE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND ANY OTHER. ASPECTS THAT YOU
THAT YOU HAVE THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU OF VERY MUCH I'M
VERY HONORED AND PLEASED TO BE
HERE CHAIRMEN AJ CAL SKI AND A
GERMAN CORK I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
AND SPEAK TO YOU AGAIN. TO YOU.
VERY PLAIN. LEE ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BEEN FACED
IN OUR COUNTY AND THAT IS THE.
EXIDE FACILITY IN SOMETHING THAT
SOME OF YOU I BELIEVE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY OUR COUNTY STAFF ARE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. WHO'S JOINED ME LOW
DOCTOR ANGELO PALOMA AND ALSO OF
WE HAVE MISTER DOCTOR ADAM LOVE
WHO'S OUR EXPERT WHO'S BEEN
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES. SO FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS SINCE I
BECAME A SUPERVISOR.
THIS CONUNDRUM I LIKE TO SAY.
EXIDE. HAS BEEN BUBBLING UP OF
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THAT I SEE
IT IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF.
TOXIC EXPENSIVE SINCE CONTROL
HAS NOT REALLY. BEEN BEEN AT THE
HELM. TO HELP US OF PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATE SUPPORT REMEDIATION
BUT ALSO LEADERSHIP AND I REALLY
HAVE TO COMMAND OF. THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER WHO PRESENTED HIS REPORT
ABOUT THE LACK OF OF LEADERSHIP
ACCOUNTABILITY RESPONSIBILITY
AND IN PARTICULAR INVOLVEMENT
WITH COMMUNITY AND THAT'S REALLY
WHY I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
WHY IT'S IMPORTANT. FOR YOU ALL
TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN SUFFERING. A NOT JUST
IN THREE YEARS BUT A HE DID HAVE
A NUMBER OF DECADES THIRTY THREE
YEARS BECAUSE OF THE.
PERMITTING PROCESS THAT WAS
LACKING IN OVERSIGHT ANY LEGAL
PERMIT AND THE FACT THAT.
THAT FACILITY WAS ALLOWED TO
OPERATE.
FOR SO MANY YEARS WHEN I CAME
IN WE DECIDED WE WERE GOING TO
TRY TO ASSIST IN ANY WAY WE
COULD TO WORK WITH THE STATE TO
WORK WITH OUR LEGISLATORS. AND
THE COUNTY'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
LOOK AT HEALTH IN TERMS OF WHAT
THOSE IMPACTS ARE AND WHAT WHAT
WE DID WAS. TRY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND I'M VERY PLEASED
I HAVE TO SAY THAT THE GOVERNOR.
OF HEARD US AND HEARD OUR VOICES
AT LAST YEAR WE ACTUALLY BROUGHT
UP.
FIFTY RESIDENTS THAT CAME FROM
EAST LOS ANGELES AND ACTUALLY
WALKED THE HALLS AND TALKED
PEOPLE ABOUT. THEIR EXPERIENCE
HAVING TO LIVE THROUGH.
THE LEAD CONTAMINATION IN PLACE
ANYWAY ACTUALLY BROUGHT
INDIVIDUALS THAT COULD TESTIFY
ABOUT THEIR AILMENTS AS A RESULT
OF THE EXPOSURE OVER THE YEARS
AND WHAT THAT MEANS. TO THEIR
FAMILIES THEIR CHILDREN AND TO.
INDIVIDUALS LIVE IN RESIDE IN
THE COUNTY.
GOVERNOR DID PROVIDE A HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX.
DOLLARS FOR THE CLEAN UP EFFORT.
BUT AFTER TELL YOU THAT ALL
RIGHT NOW IS IT'S DOWN STANDS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
STILL REMAINS IN THAT ACCOUNT
WE'VE ONLY SEEN I BELIEVE ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY I THINK
IT'S TWO HUNDRED SIXTY HOMES
THAT HAVE ACTUALLY. BEEN.
CLEANED OR SOME REMEDIATION HAS
HAPPENED.
BUT THEY FAIL TO MEET THEIR
THEIR OWN DEADLINES AND THEIR
OWN.
PLANNING SO MANY MANY THINGS
THAT YOU HEARD EARLIER I WOULD I
WOULD SAY YES WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO STICK TO THEIR PLANS. THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY MEET THEIR BUDGET
GOALS AS WELL AND IF THEY NEED
TO HAVE MORE COOPERATION WITH
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
INVOLVED. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC ART DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ACTUALLY.
WAS VERY COMMITTED TO GETTING
RESPONSE FROM OUR COMMUNITY AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID
IMMEDIATELY WAS WHAT I LIKE TO
SAY PUT BOOTS OUT ON THE GROUND.
AND ACTUALLY TOOK A SATURDAY
AFTERNOON WITH ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED VOLUNTEERS TO GO DOOR TO
DOOR TO TALK TO ACTUAL PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED IN THE
RADIUS OF ONE POINT. SEVEN MILES
IT WAS DETERMINED BY DEE DEE TSC
AND WE STARTED TO TALK TO PEOPLE
AND NOT SURPRISING PEOPLE SAID
YES WE'VE HEARD ABOUT XIV. WERE
UNCLEAR ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING NO ONE'S REALLY TALKED
TO US ABOUT THIS AND TOLD US
WHAT THE DANGERS ARE WE WE DO
KNOW THOUGH THAT WE HAVE HEALTH
AILMENTS. WE HAVE CHILDREN WITH
ASTHMA WE HAVE CHILDREN WITH
LEARNING DISABILITIES WE HAVE
PEOPLE ON ONE BLOCK THAT I
WALKED WITH STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS.
OF. MAYBE SEVEN HOUSEHOLDS WHERE
A NEIGHBOR POINTED OUT EACH HOME
SAYING.
THOSE THAT FAMILY WAS IMPACTED
BY CANCER AND AND JUST WENT DOWN
THE LINE AND IT WAS VERY
SHOCKING. FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
JUST YOU KNOW ANECDOTALLY HEAR
THAT FROM NEIGHBORS THAT LIVE
THERE AND AND.
FELT THAT THERE WAS REALLY A
NEGLIGENCE ON THE PART OF THE
STATE AND AS WELL AS THE COUNTY
BECAUSE THEY BLAME ANYBODY IN
GOVERNMENT FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET OUT THERE AND RECTIFY THIS
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
WE HAD ANOTHER CURRENTS ANOTHER
PART OF THE COUNTY OF THE SO
CANYON WHERE YOU SAW AN
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION AND FORCE
AND.
LAWYERS AND ALL EVERYONE WAS
PAYING FULL ATTENTION TO THAT
INCLUDING THE STATE AND THE
GOVERNOR WE DIDN'T SEE THAT WITH
EXCITING WE STILL HAVEN'T SEEN
IT.
WE STILL FEEL THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN NEGLECTED IN TERMS
OF THE KIND OF OUTREACH AND
PERFORMANCE BY DTS SEE A WE DID
I BELIEVE A BETTER THE
RELATIVELY SHORT. OF
PATTERN AND TIME AND ALSO COME
BACK WITH RESULTS AND TELL
PEOPLE AT WHAT LEVEL THEIR
HOUSES WERE IMPACTED BY BY THE
LEAD AND ALSO THEN WE'RE ABLE TO
DO THAT. THROUGH OUR THROUGH OUR
OWN FUNDING WE DID THAT THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT
BUT WHAT I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU
IS THAT.
SINCE THE BEGINNING AND I
UNDERSTAND AND I HAVE SAT DOWN
AND I ACTUALLY MET.
BARBARA LEE AND HER STAFF THEY
DECIDED TO SET UP A COMMITTEE
FOR THE COMMUNITY BUT AT THIS
POINT IF YOU WERE TO ASK THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF THERE'S
BEEN ANY STRONG RESULTS ARE
ACTION. THINK MANY OF THEM WOULD
SAY NO. DID NOTE THAT THEY
THEY'RE BEEN NEGLIGENT IN IN
ACTUALLY LISTENING TO THEM AND
GIVING THEM FEEDBACK AS TO WHAT
THE PROGRESS IS AND WHAT THEIR
ACTUAL PLAN IS IN AND IF IN FACT
THEY STUCK TO THEIR PLAN. SINCE
THEY STARTED THE CLEANUP WE HAD
TO GO BACK IN BECAUSE OF THE
COMMUNITY WANTED THE E. I. ARE
DONE THAT ALSO PUSH THIS BACK SO
WE'RE NOW OUT SEVERAL MONTHS IN
TERMS OF THE CLEAN UP. SINCE
THAT TIME I'VE BEEN TOLD THERE
HAS BEEN NO FURTHER CLEANUP AND
FURTHER MORE WHAT I BELIEVE IS A
IS A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM. IS
THAT.
WHEN THEY DID. ROLL OUT A PLAN
TO SAY THEY WOULD BEGIN A CLEAN
UP FADED TALK ABOUT CLEANING
INSIDE THE INTERIOR OF THE HOMES
OR THE PARKWAY IN FRONT OF THE
HOMES WE HAVE. A MATERIALS THAT
WE SHARED WITH YOU SO HOW IS HOW
IS IT FOR A RESULT PERSON TO
BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE CLEANING
SOMEONE'S SOIL IN THEIR FRONT
YARD. BUT YOU'RE NOT CLEANING
THE PARKWAY WHERE YOU GET OFF
THE CARTER CAR OFF THE SIDEWALK
AND YOU'RE WALKING IN YOUR HOME
AND YOUR CHILD OR ANYONE THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO. BRING THAT
SAME ELEMENT OR CONTAMINANTS IN
YOUR HOME.
YOU'RE NOT CLEANING IN MY
OPINION THE WAY THAT YOU
SUBSTANTIALLY SHOULD. PROCEED IN
FACT.
IT WAS ALMOST LAUGHABLE THAT
DAY US SAID THAT.
WERE KNOCKING INSISTED PEOPLE
CLEAR CLEAN THEIR INTERIOR BUT
WE'LL GIVE YOU A COUPON AND YOU
CAN USE
ZACH COUPON AND GO AND UP
CONTACT THESE PEOPLE AND THEY'LL
COME IN AND THEY'LL. VACUUM BUT
IT WASN'T THE APPROPRIATE
STANDARD OF CLEAN UP THAT I KNOW
OUR DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WOULD REQUIRE AND AND I I KNOW
DOCTOR BELONG OR WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT. BUT THERE ARE MANY
INSTANCES WHERE THERE'S BEEN A
FAILURE NO ONE EVEN EXPLAIN TO
THE RESIDENTS WITH THAT COUPON
WAS. IT YOU COULDN'T
DIFFERENTIATE WHAT IT WAS YOU
WOULD THINK IT WAS JUST AN
ADVERTISEMENT IN FACT MANY
PEOPLE TOLD ME THEY THREW IT
AWAY ONE OFMY STAFFERS. WHO
LIVES IN THE AREA ACTUALLY
BROUGHT THE COUPON IN AND I
THOUGHT WELL THERE'S NOTHING
HERE TO DISTINGUISH THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING COMING FROM THE STATE
OR SOMETHING THAT IS OF URGENCY?
SO THAT TO ME.
CAUSES ME GREAT CONCERN THAT
JUST THE LACK OF RESPECT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY FOR EVEN THE STAKE
HOLDERS AND THE DIFFERENT.
PARTICIPANTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING DONE IN A IN THIS IN
THIS SHORT PERIOD OF TIME I AM
CONCERNED ALSO THAT THE CURRENT
BUDGET DOES NOT. ALLOW FOR IT
THERE HAS TO BE SOME MOVEMENT
OBVIOUSLY BY THE.
BUDGET OF SUBCOMMITTEES TO PUT
FUNDING AND I GET TO SO WE CAN
HAPPEN SO WE CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
THE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
SO DETAILS HE COULD CONTINUE. I
BEGIN THEIR CLEANUP.
THEY HAVE A PLAN OF A I THINK
THAT.
WE HAVE MANY MANY QUESTIONS.
REGARDING AND WOULD HOPE THAT.
YOU WILL YOU WILL HEAR OUR
PLEASE AND AND WORK WITH US WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO SEE MORE
FUNDING BECAUSE WE THINK WE CAN
DO IT MORE EFFICIENTLY WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY WORKING WITH THE
TSC. BUT OBVIOUSLY HEARING
ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE IF WE'VE
ALREADY PROVEN THAT WE CAN PUT
BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND START TO
DO TESTING AND OTHER THINGS WHY
IN THE WORLD. CAN'T THE STATE OR
THIS DEPARTMENT GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER. AND THIS ISN'T A
CRITICISM ON ON THE GOVERNOR
BECAUSE I THINK YOU KNOW HE
APPROPRIATELY PLACED SOME
FUNDING THERE BUT WE NEED MORE
AND. WE'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU THE COUNTY IS AND THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE IS ONE MEMBER OF THE
BOARD
I ALSO BROUGHT WITH ME PUT A
PETITION SIGNED BY OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE. THAT JUST OVER
THE WEEKEND SAID WE'D LIKE TO
SEE SOMETHING HAPPEN OKAY. COULD
WE HEAR FROM YOUR EXPERT
WITNESSES ABOUT TWO MINUTES
EACH.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANGELA
GLOBAL DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
HEALTH PROTECTION.
BECAUSE THE SUPERVISORS COMMENTS
REFLECT WE ARE FOCUSED LIKE A
LASER LIGHT ON.
THE X. SIDE COMMUNITY AND THE
CLEAN UP THAT'S GOING ON THERE.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
BOARD IN THE I. R. THE I. RP.
HAD A RESPONSIBILITY LOOK ACROSS
THE PROGRAMS WITHIN THE DTS SEE
AND COME UP WITH WORK
RECOMMENDATIONS. SUPERVISOR
ASKED ME TO PUT TOGETHER SOME
COMMENTS ON THE RECOMMENDATION I
JUST LIKE TO. MAYBE MAKE A WORD
OR TWO ABOUT SIX OF THEM.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT.
.
TO BUILD AFFECTED RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND TO REGAIN
TRUST BECAUSE ONCE YOU LOSE
THAT.
WE'RE NO LONGER EFFECTIVE AT
DOING OUR JOBS AND I THINK. THAT
IS SOMETHING THE DTS SEE ON
THEIR STAFF FEEL EVERY TIME THEY
GO INTO THE COMMUNITY IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR THEM TO CONDUCT
THEIR WORK BECAUSE ONCE YOU LOSE
THAT TRUST. IT'S JUST THE.
A BATTLE. SO I THINK.
.
PUTTING THE EFFORT THERE AS IT
IS REFERENCED IN THE I. R. PEACH
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S A VITAL WE
LIKE ALL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT. WERE INCLUDED IN MR
CRACKLES REPORT. BUT THIS IS ONE
THAT WE THINK SHOULD HIGHLIGHT
WE NEED TO HIGHLIGHT. ANOTHER
ONE IS CLOSE COLLABORATIONS WITH
LOCAL REGULATORY PARTNERS. AND
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS WE THINK THAT.
EXIDE WE TALK A LOT ABOUT IT BUT
IT'S BECAUSE IT'S EMBLEMATIC AND
IT'S A REALLY GOOD SYMBOL FOR A
LOT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT. WERE
REFERENCED BEFORE WE EVEN CAME
UP HERE. BECAUSE ALMOST
EVERYTHING YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S A SET SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING. HOW DO WE MAINTAIN
THOSE FUNDING STREAMS HOW DO WE
ADEQUATELY FUND THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT? THOSE WERE ALL
PLAYED OUT IT EXCITE THE REASON
WHY THIS BECAME A PUBLICLY
FINANCED.
OBJECT IS BECAUSE THE FINANCIAL
ASSURANCES THAT WERE REQUIRED IN
THE LAW WERE NEVER UPDATED FOR
EXCITE.
THE NEXT OF THE THIRD OF.
RECOMMENDATION WAS THE CREATION
OF AN OVERSIGHT BOARD AND I
WON'T COMMENT ON THAT ANYMORE
THAN GIDEON DID. OTHER THAN TO
SAY THAT. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT THAT
ABILITY OF AN OVERSIGHT BODY.
STRENGTHENING THE FINANCIAL
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES SO THAT WE
DON'T.
REALLY UP PUT THESE BURDENS ON
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
FUND THINGS WHERE YOU HAVE AN
ACTIVE. OPERATING FACILITY WHO'S
WHO'S BRINGING IN REVENUE.
AWHILE THEY'RE ACTING BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES IN PLACE. AND THEN OF
THE FAITH THE A FIFTH. THE FIVE
YEAR REVIEWS FOR A LONG TERM
SITE CLEANUPS ESSENTIAL
RECOMMENDATION. WE REALLY SAW
THAT PLAYING OUT IN EXCITED
BECAUSE IF THIS CLEAN UP IS NOT
IMPLEMENTED. WITH THE NECESSARY
CHANGES IT IN THE WAY IT IS
IMPLEMENTED. WILL BE REVISITING
THIS AGAIN AT SOME POINT AND
WE'LL HAVE TO GO BACK TO THOSE
SITES.
MEN OF THE LAST ONE BEING THE
CREATION OF THE STATE WIDE. TASK
FORCE ON LEAD THERE IS NO
CHEMICAL IN THE WORLD IT IS MORE
EXTENSIVELY STUDY THAN LEAD. BUT
WE STILL HAVE UP POISONINGS AND
EXPOSURES THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
HAVING. AND I THINK THIS IS ONE
GOOD STEP WITHIN CALIFORNIA FOR
US TO TRY TO. TURN THAT AROUND
SOMEWHAT.
AND I JUST SIMPLY WANT TO CLOSE
BY SAYING THAT.
WITHIN THE COUNTY AND
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE ARE OPEN TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
OF. DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL. IN ANY WAY
WE CAN TO MAKE SURE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS GET IMPLEMENTED
OKAY THANK YOU AND I'M CERTAINLY
WILLING TO FACILITATE A MEETING.
WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT AND DTS
SEATED SEE WHAT MORE CAN BE DONE
TOGETHER.
SO.
PERHAPS WITH THE SENATORS HOW WE
CAN DO THAT.
YOUR FINAL WITNESS.
I THINK FROM A TECHNICAL
PERSPECTIVE RIGHT OUT OF THE
COUNTY IN DETAIL SEE I DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE EYE TO EYE NOT
ONLY ON SOME OF THE ASSESSMENTS
BUT ALSO SOME OF THE STRATEGIES
FOR CLEAN UP. AND I THINK UP
FROM A TECHNICAL PERSPECTIVE
PERSPECTIVE REALLY MORE DIALOGUE
AND TRANSPARENCY. AS TO THOSE AS
YOU KNOW THAT ASSESSMENT PROCESS
AND RATIONALE AS WELL AS SOME
ASSUMPTIONS ARE USING IN TERMS
OF DETERMINING HOW THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE CLEANED UP. IS
SOMETHING THAT STILL A DIALOGUE
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO HAVE
BECAUSE WE THINK THERE'S SOME
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THEY'RE MAKING
THAT DON'T ALLOW THE COMMUNITY
ULTIMATELY TO BE CONFIDENT. THAT
WHEN THEY'RE DONE THE HOMES WILL
BE CLEAN AND SAFE TO RETURN TO.
KNOW IT FROM A TECHNICAL
PERSPECTIVE YOU NEED CAN NEVER
HAVE A HUNDRED PERCENT
CONFIDENCE BUT WE DO FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE BETTER METHODOLOGIES TO
EMPLOY THAT WILL GIVE THE
COMMUNITY MUCH BETTER CONFIDENCE
AND WHAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
PROPOSED.
THANK YOU. I WILL MENTION SIMPLY
MEMBER SEAN THIAGO IS BROUGHT
FORWARD A BILL TO PARTICULAR
LOOK AT THE PARK. SAID THAT TO A
SUPERVISOR A. SILLY SAYS
MENTIONED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL CONTINUE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY PLEASE TRY TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO ROUGHLY
TWO MINUTES.
AND GIVE US YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND OUT FOR YOU
FROM.
THE MICROPHONE. HELLO YEAH SO.
A MICROPHONE IS RIGHT HERE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS INGRID
ROSTRUM I'M WITH THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND I'M ALSO AT THE CALIFORNIA
BY MISTER JUSTICE ALLIANCE. ON.
I WANTED TO START. MY RESPONSE
ME I'M JUST HAVING A LITTLE
TROUBLE HEARING YOU KNOW PERHAPS
A BETTER LOOK CLOSE TO THE
MICROPHONE AND START YOUR
INTRODUCTION AGAIN. MY NAME IS
INGRID ROSTRUM I'M WITH THE
CENTER ON RACE POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ALSO AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE THAT IS MUCH BETTER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND I DID
WANT TO.
A QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED IN
THE BEGINNING ARM ASKING PUBLIC
COMMENTERS VERY QUICKLY TO SAY
WHAT HAS IMPROVED AND I WILL
SAY.
HAVING BEEN VERY INTIMATELY
INVOLVED WITH THIS AGENCY FOR.
ABOUT A DECADE ON.
THAT THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND TRIBAL AFFAIRS.
IT IS BEEN VERY OPPRESSIVE TO ME
AND WITH GOOD DEDICATED STAFF
AND STAFF LEVELS ON WE ALSO BEEN
IMPRESSED WITH SOME OF. THE
POSITIONS BEING FILLED AT THE
HIGHER LEADERSHIP LEVELS AS WELL
AS SOME.
PEOPLE IN THOSE POSITIONS
LEAVING THAT PROBABLY NEEDED TO
LIVE AWHILE AGO SO THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT I WILL SAY WE HAVE
BEEN IMPRESSED WITH.
SOME OF THE DIFFICULTIES THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE.
REALLY ESPECIALLY AFTER THE I
RP HAS BEEN DISBANDED IS THIS
ISSUE OF WHERE DO. IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED RESIDENTS
AGO WHEN THESE ISSUES THAT
FAILED TO BE RESOLVED YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR. THE I RP WAS
THE ONLY.
PLACE ARE ONLY BODY OUR PEOPLE
COULD RAISE THESE CONCERNS SO
THERE IS A BIG CONCERN ABOUT
WHAT DO WE DO NOW. THE STATUS
QUO HAS NOT WORKED FOR MANY
DECADES FOR THESE COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE THIS SAME ISSUE WITH
THEM IS DEADLINES ON YES. SP SIX
SEVENTY THREE THAT DEADLINE HAS
COME AND GONE AND I'M
SURPRISINGLY THEY HAVE THEY HAVE
FAILED TO MEET THAT. OF HER
MEETING WITH THE WITH THE
BACKLOG FIBER ATTACK STILL IS ON
AN EXPIRED PERMIT THAT EXPIRED
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES. AND
EVEN WITH CLEAN UPS.
WE HAD IN DELANO WHERE OUR
OFFICES WE HAD A CONTAMINATED
WITH CONTAMINATION DISCOVERED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX AND TEN
YEARS LATER THE COMMUNITY WAS
INFORMED. THAT WE HAVE THIS
PATTERN OF LONG DELAYS.
INFORMATION GAPS AND
COMMUNITIES NOT HAVING ANYWHERE
TO TURN. AND THE MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
WE'RE NOT REALLY IN MY MIND
GOING TO. SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
THAT DTS SEE UNLESS WE REALLY
TACKLE THE STRUCTURE IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS. IT
ISN'T INSULAR. AGENCY BUT YET IT
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
AGENCIES IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
STATE.
BUT NOW FOR CONTAMINATED SITES
OR MEDIATION SITES AND
PERMITTING. WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S
THE DECISION MAKERS AS A AS A
RESIDENCE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
BASIS DECISIONS ARE ON. SET WITH
YOUR TWO MINUTES IS UP COULD YOU
JUST FINISH UP.
YES ARM. THERE'S NO
STANDARDIZED.
.
THERE'S NO STANDARDS WHICH WE
CAN APPLY AND THE APPEAL PROCESS
IS BROKEN SO UNLESS WE REALLY
DEAL WITH THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES
AT DTS SEE I DON'T THINK WE'RE
GOING TO RESOLVE THINGS AND THIS
AD HOC WAY SO WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE IRAQIS
RECOMMENDATIONS. ESPECIALLY ON
THE STRUCTURAL REFORMS THINK
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR VERY
VALUABLE TESTIMONY.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANDREA
VENTURA I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION. AND WE HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH PTSD SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS REGULATORY
PROCESS.
AND THERE IS ONE THING IT WASN'T
REALLY DISCUSSED HERE IN THE
TESTIMONY BUT THERE IS ONE THING
IN THE REPORT THAT WE DO. HAVE A
BIT OF.
CONCERNED ABOUT AND THAT IS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PULL BACK AND NOT
REALLY ACT ON CHEMICALS OR AT
LEAST INTERFERE WITH THAT
PROGRAM. THAT CAME UP DURING THE
HEARING BY INDUSTRY INTERESTS.
BECAUSE THERE WAS LEGISLATION
TO PUT THINGS INTO THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS RAKES THE
REASON WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT IS THAT WE'RE KIND OF
FEELING STUCK IN CALIFORNIA WERE
BETWEEN A ROCK AND A HARD PLACE
AT THIS POINT. ON CHEMICAL
POLICY REFORM. THIS IF A
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM WHICH
WE TOTALLY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
THE INNOVATION AND THE STAFF
WORKING ON IT. ARM THE REALITY
IS HOWEVER THAT THAT IS A TEN
YEAR PROGRAM THAT HAS NOT
PRODUCED A SINGLE ALTERNATIVE
ANALYSIS YET. IT IS PARTIALLY A
RESOURCE ISSUE AND GETTING
STARTED AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
BUT IT IS ALSO A PROGRAM THAT
HAS BEEN TIMID IN USING ITS OWN
AUTHORITY TO MOVE FORWARD. IN
OUR OPINION. AND THAT IS WHY WE
HAVE COME TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
WITH SUPPORT FROM. FROM BOTH OF
THE YOUR COMMITTEES.
HAVE MOVE SOME LEGISLATION ON
CHEMICAL POLICY. BUT WHAT I WANT
TO JUST BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
IS THAT WE HEAR FROM DTS SEE AND
FROM AND FROM CAL EPA IS. DON'T
MESS WITH MR OUR PROGRAM ITS
SCIENTIFIC. AND WE AGREE WITH IT
IN A PERFECT WORLD THAT THAT'S
THE WAY IT SHOULD BE. BUT IT IS
A DELIBERATIVE PROCESS IT WILL
ALWAYS BE SLOW AND IT WAS NEVER
MEANT TO ABROGATE THE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO AT TIMES TO TAKE.
ACTION ON CHEMICALS THAT ARE
CAUSING SERIOUS EXPOSURES TO
CALIFORNIANS AND.
NEED TO BE ERADICATED SO WE
JUST WAIT BECAUSE WE HEAR FROM
THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE GOT SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS WE HEAR FROM
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
DON'T MESS WITH US. AND
NOTHING'S HAPPENING OKAY OKAY
YOU VERY MUCH FRANK YOU RELEVANT
TESTIMONY.
LEO ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
A FIRST I AGREE WITH MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT.
MISPRINTS FROM MADE FROM CRP
ABOUT STRUCTURAL REFORM NEEDED
TO TSC. BUT I MAINLY WANT TO
STICK TO THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM AGREEING WITH
THAT MS CENTER OF THAT IT'S
MOVING WAY TOO SLOWLY. WAY
LONGER THAN THE LEGISLATURE
CERTAINLY INTENDED WHEN IT WAS
PASSED.
CERTAINLY MORE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED. BUT WE WOULD DISAGREE
WITH ONE OF OUR RECOMMENDATION
OR A COMMENT MADE BY THE R. P.
WHICH IS MAYBE THEY SET
UNREALISTIC DEADLINES AND THEY
SHOULD SET. BEING A MORE
REALISTIC AND SET ABOUT I DON'T
THINK SO BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
SLOW SLOWLY NOW. LET'S GET IT
DONE FASTER LASTLY ON THE ISSUE
OF THE LEGISLATURE TAKING.
ACTION IN LIEU OF OR INSTEAD OF
IT'S PERFECTLY ALLOWABLE THE LAW
NEVER SAYS THIS WILL BE THE SOLE
PREROGATIVE OF THE. GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM TO DO THAT AND
AS WE MOVE INTO THE NEXT DECADE
OF THE PROGRAM I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO LOOK AT.
SINGLE CHEMICAL BAND BILLS WERE
A A DIRTY WORD AFTER AWHILE BUT
SOMETIMES THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH SOONER
THAN DTS HE IS ABLE TO UNTIL
IT'S FULLY STAFFED UP OR
WHATEVER YOU DO THEY GET TO SO
IT'S. MORE RAPID AND PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU TOM JACOB.
AFTER THE CHEMICAL INDUSTRY
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
I JUST LIKE TO COMMENT A LITTLE
BIT.
AS THE TWO PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
HAVE.
ON ELEMENTS OF.
DTS THESE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
SENT CENTRALLY AT ISSUE IN TERMS
OF HAZARDOUS WASTE AND CLEAN UPS
AND THAT'S. THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM AND ALSO.
THE POLLUTION PREVENTION
PROGRAM WHICH.
GIDEON HAD REFERENCED IN HIS
TESTIMONY.
THAT.
DISAPPEARED. WE'VE SUPPORTED
BOTH OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
.
WE DIFFER WITH THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS IN TERMS OF.
THE PACE OF THE STP THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM. IT
HAS BEEN DELIBERATE IT'S BEEN
FRUSTRATING.
WE DO THINK THAT SOME OF THAT
IS.
RELATED TO.
MANPOWER QUESTIONS.
SOME OF IT QUITE FRANKLY THOUGH
IS RELATED TO THE FACT THAT.
THAT WAS A PIONEERING.
REGULATION THE STATUTES WERE
NEW TRAILS HERE.
COVERING NEW GROUND FROM A
REGULATORY STANDPOINT.
AND WE THINK IT'S BEEN AN
APPROPRIATELY DELIBERATE.
PROCESS. I ALSO BELIEVE AND I
THINK THIS IS A COMMONLY. SHARED
BELIEF.
THAT THEY'RE POISED TO MOVE
MUCH MORE RAPIDLY.
NOW THAT THEY'VE GOT THEIR.
INITIAL SEVERAL. PRODUCTS.
MOVING AND THEY'VE HAD THE
EXPERIENCE OF THAT PROCESS.
I'D LIKE TO ALSO.
MENTION RELATED CONCERN NOW AND
THAT IS.
THAT AS WE ATTEND TO THE
PROBLEMS WHICH WE CERTAINLY
DON'T DISPUTE.
THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY I THINK WE CAN'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT DTS HE
HAS A LARGER SUITE OF.
RESPONSIBILITIES AND.
THOSE.
DO NEED TO BE TAKEN.
INTO COGNIZANCE AS WE CONSIDER.
HOW TO REMEDY THE PROBLEMS WE
WOULD NOT WANT TO SEE? RADICAL
STEPS TAKEN. THAT ARE DRIVEN.
LARGELY BY A HANDFUL OF SITES
WHERE WE HAVE.
ISSUES.
THAT WOULD. MAKE CHANGES THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE THE INTEGRITY OF
THE LARGER SUITE OF ACTIVITY
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR.
.
VERY.
APROPOS TESTIMONY. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND.
HAVING HEARD THREE OF YOU NOW
SPEAKING TO THAT PROGRAM WE
COULD CERTAINLY.
I'LL BE TAKING THAT FURTHER
LOOK AT IT. TOP PERHAPS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE HERE.
.
YES.
GO AHEAD RANDALL FRIEDMAN ON
BEHALF OF NAVY REGION SOUTHWEST
WHICH OPERATES FOR HAZARDOUS
WASTE PERMITS ESSENTIAL TO OUR
MISSION. I'D ALSO POINT OUT THE
EAR FORCE OPERATES THREE HOUSE
RACE FACILITIES MAKING THE
MILITARY A MAJOR STAKEHOLDER IN
THE PERMITTING ISSUES. I'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK AND
THOUGHT THAT WENT INTO THE I RP
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF CHAIRMAN
CRACK OFF. THE FINAL REPORT
RECOGNIZES A SERIOUS ISSUE THE
MILITARY BROUGHT TO THEM. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOMMENDATION.
THAT APPLICANTS BE GIVEN QUOTE A
REASONABLE ASSURANCE OF COSTS
AND THAT A MECHANISM BE
DEVELOPED. TO HOLD THE TSC
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE
ASSURANCES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU THIS YEAR ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS IN A
BASKET SOME YOUNG BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ARMS JUSTICE ALLIANCE
AND I JUST WANNA FINISH
APPALLING OR NEAR THE MARMOSET
DOES THIS ALLIANCE AND I JUST
WANT TO FINISH THE POINT ON FROM
THE FIRST SPEAKER. IN A REALLY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AND SPECIFICALLY OF
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE SEEING THESE
FACILITIES NOT BE REGULATED HOW
THEY SHOULD BE REGULATED BY THIS
DEPARTMENT. I REALLY COMMAND ARE
PEOPLE PROCESSES AND COME IN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS EVER SEEN BUT
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE ITS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THERE'S A LOT
OF RECOMMENDATIONS ARE REALLY.
SUBSTANTIAL HOWEVER WE HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF THEM NOT BE
IMPLEMENTED OR HAVE BEEN
ACTUALLY FIND IT TO BE
IMPLEMENTED TO REALLY
CONSIDERING THOSE. DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS ALSO I'M REALLY COMMEND
SURPRISED HER PHILLIES FOR
COMNG OUT I'M IN REALLY
SPEAKING ON THIS ISSUE GIVEN THE
WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN THE
COMMUNITY OF THE SILLY WITH
EXIDE BUT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE INCIDENTS ARE NOT
ISOLATED TO SPECIFICALLY. LA BUT
LOOKING AT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF HOW MANY MORE INCIDENTS AND
NOT BE REPORTED AND DON'T HAVE
SOMEBODY LIKE SUPERVISED RELEASE
TO BE HERE. TO REALLY ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF THEM SO WITHOUT
REALLY BE MINDFUL THAT THIS IS
NOT JUST IN SELLING CALIFORNIA
BITS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL. REFORM THAT CAN
ACTUALLY SERVE ALL CALIFORNIANS
SO THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK.
TOM I WILL GET THIS OVER TO THE
SENATE.
WE'RE DONE WE'RE GAVEL WE'RE
DONE.
WHERE DO I GET THIS? YEAR.
WE'RE DONE THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH